Hi everyone, my name is Offer from
Victara. I run our developer relations
and I'm going to talk to you today about
open rag evil, a new open source project
for quick and scalable rag evaluation.
You can use the QR code here to get to
the repo
directly. So what is open rag eval? It's
a open source project that is aiming to
solve one of the major problems of rag
evaluation. the fact that you require
golden answers or golden chunks to do
anything which is really nonscalable. It
is researchbacked. So it's work that
we've done with collaboration with
University of Wateroo the Jimmy Lynn lab
specifically. And let me show you how it
works. So generally this is kind of an
architecture view of what what it does.
So you start with a set of queries. It
could be 10 or 100 or a thousand queries
that you've collected that are important
for your rag system. We have a rag
connector and that really collects all
the actual information, the actual
chunks, the actual answers that are
generated by a rag pipeline. We have one
for vector for lang chain for lama index
and a growing number of other connectors
and those connectors generally generate
these outputs shown here which is the
the rag outputs. From there you run the
actual evaluation which runs a bunch of
metrics. Metrics are grouped into
evaluators and that's kind of how the
the internal architecture works and
those evaluators generate rag evaluation
files and that has everything you need
to know to really evaluate your rag
pipeline. Now the metrics are where it
gets really interesting. How do we do
this thing with no golden answers? Well,
there's a few metrics I want to mention
here that are part of this package. One
is called umbrella. It's really allows
you to do retrieval without the golden
chunks. The other one is called
autonogizer. I'll talk more about this
for generation. We have the citation
faithfulness which measures whether
citations in the response are really
correct and hallucination detection
which is based on Victara's
hallucination detection model. So, let's
go into each of these in detail.
Umbrella is a retrieval metric as I
mentioned and what it does is it
actually takes a chunk and gives it a
score between zero and three. Zero being
that this chunk or passage has nothing
to do with the query and three being
that it's dedicated to the query and
contains the exact answer. Now the nice
thing about this is not just the scale
here which is pretty self-explanatory
but the fact that the research done by
the University of Wateroo lab of Jim
Lynn shows that if you use this approach
it correlates well with human judgment
and that is really really powerful. So
if you use this even without the golden
chunks you know that the results will be
good.
Now auto nuggetizer is the generation
metric and again it doesn't require the
golden answers in this case and it works
a little bit differently. There's three
steps here. The first step is nugget
creation where you create these atomic
units called nuggets. Then for each
nugget you assign a vital or okay
rating. You sort of sort these nuggets
by get the top 20. And then there's a
step where an LLM judge analyzes the
response you get from your rag to
determine if each of the selected
nuggets is either fully supported or
partially supported by the answer.
Again, you can see all of this in the
papers in in much more detail. The third
metric is citation faithfulness which
essentially measures whether the
citation the passage you know is high
fidelity. It's it's it's fully supported
partially supported or there's no
support for the citation in the
response. And then the last one is
really using HHM, Vector's Hallucination
detection model to check if the entire
response aligns with the retrieve
content. So that's a that's the metrics
we have. And there's also a very cool
user interface for this. So once you
finish with your running your
evaluation, you can of course look at
the files yourself, but that's tends to
be pretty complex. So you can drag and
drop those files onto open evaluation.ai
AI as shown here and you get this really
really cool UI that shows you all the
queries you ran and all the things that
you want to compare between the
retrieval scores, the different
generation scores,
etc. And that's it. So I encourage you
to take a look at this. It's a very
powerful package can help you optimize
and and tune your your rag pipeline.
Again, it's open source, so all the
sources open. You can take a look and
see how it works. This drives a lot of
transparency. So the metrics are very
clear in how they work. As I said, it
includes connectors to vectara, langlama
index. But if you have your own rag
pipeline or some other rag pipeline you
want to contribute, we're very much in
favor of contributing other issues or
PRs for other connectors. And let us
know if you have any questions. This is
about open rock evil and thank you for
listening.